our series a more perfect union shows
that what unites us as americans is far
greater than what divides us the
holidays can be a tough time for
military families they might have a
parent deployed overseas or they may
themselves be dealing with the wounds of
war overseas one company is on a mission
to brighten those lives this time of the
year in particular and they are uniquely
qualified to do so janet chamlion joined
these good folks for a surprise mission
in the great smoky mountains
it's been years of hard knocks for
geisha alvarez
yesterday i'm brandon stevens so she
never expects good news you're nominated
by multiple friends and family and we're
here to decorate your house
are you serious yes
[Music]
now it's time to execute a secret plan
in the works for weeks
yards of garland hundreds of lights
thousands of dollars in decorations
over the next few hours this home will
become the best dressed in rural
colorway north carolina are you ever a
little worried when you knock on
somebody's door sort of unannounced and
especially so when you don't know if you
know they know that you're coming
brandon stevens is the president of
christmas decor which sells and installs
just that
but each year he and his franchise
partners give the decorations away to
some 200 families through a nomination
process military first responders and
local heroes
few stories this year match that of
geisha alvarez we have
three girls five boys
from 17 to seven how do you do it
i still try to figure out every day how
i'm doing it beyond eight children
geisha is her husband's caregiver angel
survived an ied blast during the war in
iraq he still suffers traumatic brain
injuries we were
homeless
for quite some time
and
we've gone through a lot of things angel
has since been diagnosed with cancer
twice
to provide for her family geisha went
back to school last year and got her
high school degree she's now in college
third semester
i just made the dean's list
honorable for associates in applied
science in medical billing and coding
remarkably still finding time for others
collecting toys for operation home front
christmas lights bring such joy to
people and such happiness really nice
mariella nichols and a half dozen others
made magic for hours stringing lights
draping garland yeah right there right
there
arranging the snowflakes the snowman and
the star
there you go
geisha and angel were the first to get a
glimpse
i would cry
[Music]
this is so
awesome but as the kids came home from
school and the sun set who wants to lead
the countdown the full glory of the gift
revealed
three
two
one
[Music]
not used to
receiving anything especially people
donating their time to
they took out of their family to come
here and do this for us so
it's pretty amazing in the great smoky
mountains a jolt of joy for a special
family the holidays illuminated
janet shamley and just
doing some great reporting right there
lighting up their lives and also
lighting up our hearts right here
yeah joltejoy is right there's something
about christmas lights on your house
though that just make you feel good when
you just pull into the driveway and
she's got what did she say three girls
and five boys
kids love that kind of stuff so mom and
dad do too yeah it's something you don't
know you need to see until you see it
like you're driving by somebody's house
you're like wow that's beautiful nice
just warms the heart that's nice
oh that was awesome